6 14 on your friday morning a really
cool art display coming to town this
summer that will literally put you
right in the middle of masterpieces by
vincent van gogh
joining me now from toronto to talk
about the immersive exhibit corey ross
one of the producers
hey good morning corey good morning
pleasure to be with you
thank you so much so we i think should
know the iconic paintings of van gogh so
tell us about this idea of putting the
person who's there
in the middle of the painting how does
that work well it's absolutely
fascinating the the
this show kind of sits at the crossroads
of
film making art exhibiting and
experiential shows
where you walk through and you have an
experience like sleep no more in new
york
so you come into the room and every
surface all the architecture of the room
is video mapped and we're projecting
massive projections we have 500
000 cubic feet of projection in the show
and so
every surface is is projected the
architecture is completely transformed
by the art
and then it's animated so one piece
becomes another
sunflowers sway in the wind clouds go by
overhead
and the stars twinkle and the experience
is all done
to a musical soundtrack and it's
completely engrossing
if you've seen emily in paris episode 5
a lot of americans have seen that
on netflix that episode happens inside
one of these exhibits in paris
um the what you're seeing on the screen
right now is our exhibition
in chicago that opened in mid february
and we have another one in toronto that
opened last july it's just a huge hit
people love it tell us about the
situation here
in las vegas i know we're not really we
don't know exactly where it is i'm
guessing you do but
you guys are throwing some mystery into
it as well yeah we always start out by
announcing a secret venue
then we find an iconic uh an interesting
place to do the show and we'll begin to
slowly unveil to the public what that is
and
and what the plans are in toronto we're
in the former printing press room of the
toronto star building
uh in chicago we're in an old german
community center
we're going to be in san francisco in
the famous fillmore nightclub
so it's always an interesting place when
we talk about van gogh
uh i think one of the things one of the
paintings that most folks know for sure
absolutely is a starry starry night and
i'm pretty sure that's going to be part
of the exhibit
yeah absolutely we've licensed 400
images of paintings from the best
museums around the world so we have
starry night with potato eaters with the
bedroom that i just saw on
on screen uh every every piece that you
know
will figure into this but the animation
of them and the reconstruction and
deconstruction and
the way the whole show happens around
you is what makes this fascinating
so we're just about out of time here so
we don't know the location but we know
i think tickets are going to go on sale
really soon and how much are they going
to cost
well tickets are on sale tomorrow at 10
a.m at
vango vegas.com and they start at 40.
excellent well corey are you going to
come down and help put this thing in or
is it already being done and we just
don't know about it
well a little bit of both i always love
coming to vegas i produce the wow
show and at the rio and extravaganza and
potted potter over at bally's had to
plug those shows
so i love coming to vegas and i come
often and i'll certainly be
there when we open this well we'll
certainly learn more as we get closer
but corey ross thank you so much for
joining us from toronto
to talk about the immersive van gogh
exhibit can't wait to see it thank you
man